[Musique]
avec nous Frédéric mirran directeur du
département du sciences politiques de
l'Université de Montréal bonsoir
bonsoir c'est la première fois depuis
son élection en 2019 que cette
présidente de la Commission européenne
visite le Canada pourquoi il le fait
maintenant
on pourrait dire que le fait parce
qu'elle est d'abord passée à Washington
et que ça fait partie d'une tournée
transatlantique mais je pense qu'il faut
souligner que les sommets entre le
Canada et l'Union européenne redevienne
importante pendant longtemps on pouvait
se demander ce qu'il allait sortir d'une
rencontre entre une Union européenne et
un Kanda qui sont certes amies mais qui
n'avaient pas de temps de choses que ça
à se dire pendant toute la décennie 2010
c'était l'accord économique et
commercial global l'accord de
libre-échange qui était vraiment au
centre des discussions aujourd'hui c'est
la guerre en Ukraine c'est la transition
énergétique or il se trouve que les deux
sont liés pour le Canada comme pour
l'Union européenne jusqu'à quel point le
Canada peut en faire plus justement en
matière énergétique pour approvisionner
l'Europe
pour la présidente van derline l'a
rappelé le Canada en produisant du gaz à
un impact sur les marchés mondiaux mais
ce n'est pas un marché très mondialisé
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
l'Union européenne depuis un an a perdu
son principal fournisseur la Russie
comment a-t-elle répondu à ce problème
d'abord en réduisant sa consommation de
manière assez importante il faut le
rappeler donc ça c'est aussi la
transition énergétique mais aussi en
diversifiant ces fournisseurs donc elle
est allée vers l'Algérie la Norvège le
Qatar et le Canada à court terme ne peut
pas exporter énormément de gaz dans
l'Union européenne à moyen terme en
revanche je pense qu'il y a des attentes
du côté européen et quand on parle
d'hydrogène mais ça fait partie aussi
disons de cet horizon dans lequel le
Canada pourrait devenir un fournisseur
pérenne de l'Union européenne en matière
énergétique qu'est-ce peu exactement
faire sur l'hydrogène parce qu'on a
annoncé une entente d'intention avec
l'Allemagne voilà un plan d'action avec
l'Union européenne est-ce que c'est des
grands discours là où on mise vraiment
en Europe sur l'hydrogène du Canada
alors moi je ne suis pas un spécialiste
de politique énergétique mais j'ai mon
sentiment fort en écoutant mes collègues
c'est que l'hydrogène et un domaine ou
un secteur une technologie qui est
encore mal connue donc c'est pas un
hasard je pense qu'il y a disons des
ambitions plutôt que des réalisations
concrètes ce qui est sûr c'est que
l'Allemagne est un pays en particulier
pour cela 22h d'école présidente de la
Commission européenne elle est aussi
allemande et l'Allemagne et le pays le
plus important dans l'Union européenne
or c'est un pays qui dépendait
énormément des hydrocarbures et un
carbure pardon et en particulier du gaz
russe c'est un pays par ailleurs qui
refuse l'énergie nucléaire alors la
question en France est complètement
différente la France mise sur l'énergie
nucléaire l'Allemagne est mise sur
l'hydrogène comme une technologie du
futur lui permettant de continuer à
alimenter son industrie avec évidemment
aussi l'éolien avec le solaire est-ce
qu'on comprend que la présidente
davantage ici pour parler d'énergie de
croissance économique de relation
économique que de l'Ukraine même si un
lien bien sûr avec l'énergie le Canada a
fait une petite annonce là pour un
soutien supplémentaire à la formation
des militaires mais fondamentalement
c'est la question énergétique qui
intéresse la présidente de la Commission
européenne
les deux sont très étroitement liés la
question énergétique est
particulièrement disons au sommet de
l'ordre du jour parce que c'est un sujet
sur lequel certes il y a des
convergences mais il y a aussi beaucoup
de choses à discuter pour en arriver à
des résultats concrets alors que sur la
question stratégique c'est à dire la
guerre en Ukraine là il y a un accord
total entre l'Union européenne et le
Canada sur un la nécessité de soutenir
diplomatiquement l'Ukraine mais aussi
d'accroître l'approvisionnement
militaire les fournitures militaires à
l'Ukraine donc c'est quand même un sujet
important et c'est un sujet sur lequel
la Commission européenne n'était pas
historiquement un acteur disons central
l'Union européenne c'est un projet de
paix mais depuis la guerre en Ukraine on
voit que le logiciel de l'Union
européenne est en train de changer avec
un pilotage de l'industrie de défense
avec un soutien financier aux
exportations militaires vers l'Ukraine
c'est en train de devenir ce que la
présidente d'airlines appelle un acteur
géopolitique est-ce que le Canada prend
toutes ses responsabilités sur le plan
énergétique que sur le plan de la guerre
sur le point de vue militaire également
dans l'oeil de la Commission européenne
est-ce que le Canada prend toutes ses
responsabilités dans ces dossiers
je pense que le regard que porte
actuellement l'Union européenne sur le
Canada est extrêmement positif certes le
Canada n'a pas la taille de l'Allemagne
ou de la France il est aussi plus loin
sur le plan géographique et il a la
politique de défense qu'il a toujours eu
c'est à dire une politique de défense
modeste mais de manière générale je
pense qu'il y a pas de critique sont
adressées au Canada sur toutes ces
questions il y a des attentes sur les
questions énergétiques sur les questions
militaires et aussi sur les questions
économiques parce que une des choses
certainement qui intéressent la
présidence van derline c'est de savoir
comment le Canada s'ajuste aux
politiques américaines je pense ici au
inflation Redemption actes donc est
aussi lié à la transition énergétique
avec ses subventions très importantes
pour les industries vertes le Canada
était un peu épargné par des mesures qui
sont souvent un peu protectionnistes
mais pas l'Union européenne et c'est une
grosse source de préoccupation en Europe
la question attend de savoir est-ce que
des industries vertes européennes qui
vont se délocaliser aux États-Unis au
Canada pour profiter des subventions
américaines donc ça c'est ça pourrait
être aussi un sujet de discussion où il
y a des choses à apprendre pour pour les
Européens comme pour les Canadiens
Ursula 20h qui va rencontrer Joe Biden
d'ailleurs un peu plus tard cette
semaine vendredi Frédéric Meyran merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
merci bonne soirée bonne soirée pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI